hi my name is Aquafina and [ __ ] hi my
name is Aquafina star of the farewell of
[ __ ] hi my name is Aquafina star the
farewell a movie about [ __ ] hi smack I'm
a great actress obviously like I do
great language hi my name is Aquafina
star of the farewell a story about
grandmas and these are my favorite
movies that I like to watch with my
grandma my relationship with my grandma
I mean she is my she's my ride-or-die
she's my BFF she gives me everything
from love to financial advice and she
believes in Me movies fit into my
relationship with my grandma because it
was a way that I could understand her
humor
I couldn't understand like the Chinese
movies she would put on and plus they
were all very like unnecessary you know
what I mean like I think I was watching
one where like this ghost music child
a ghost child comes out he's like wait
there's more and then 15 other those
children come out I was like I don't
mean I could watch us right now the
types of movies that my grandma liked
were literally only movie starring Kenan
& Kel
Martin Lawrence and or forensic science
my earliest movie memory that I would
watch with my grandma um a possibly good
burger welcome to good burger home of
the good burger can I take your order
she loved Kenan & Kel she thought Kel
was like the best and then I was on
Centre Night Live and I told her I met
Kenan and it was like the only time that
she starts drunk oh my god she was like
wow what's he like
and I was like he's great man so one
movie that my grandma watched
incessantly to the point where we
actually bought it for her on blu-ray
is a lovely film called Blue Streak in
which Martin Lawrence teams up with Luke
Wilson and to recover some diamonds that
he hid in the ceiling but this was
before you know he was and he went to
prison for a while then he comes out
come to find the diamonds are in the
ceiling of a precinct so that but oh
right
my grandma loved that movie
we watched it all the time incessantly
she can probably quote it she loved
Martin that was her man and what else
was there oh my cousin Vinnie
I watched she loves my cousin my grandma
loves my cousin Vinnie I believed that
my grandma actually told me to watch my
Cousin Vinny for the first time when I
was really young or my dad had a VHS of
it and Mike and they would talk about it
all the time and I never understood who
Vinnie would like they would always talk
about like my cousin Vinnie and then so
finally like they showed it to me and my
grandma was like very tickled by Joe
Pesci she like loves Joe like even when
I would watch home alone which was like
one of my favorite movies she'd be like
oh my cousin Vinnie his name is Joe
Pesci ya know she liked babe the one
with the pig I personally was not a fan
of babe especially not when he was a pig
in the city not as stupid as Sheep mind
you but pigs are definitely stupid
excuse me
no or not I forced my grandma to watch
tons of movies oceans a crazy urge
Asians dude on Netflix The Farewell
I got a screener my grandma has seen the
farewell I basically signed on to the
farewell as kind of because I love my
grandma so much and I like wanted to do
this and I was so happy I like asked the
studio for screeners like please give me
one screen I'll just give it to my
grandma came your screener we like sat
down to watch it and right at the part
where after the wedding like when I'm
about to like the like the like the end
my grandma gets up she gets up and she
goes I'm gonna stare cookin can you
believe that I was like Paiva told you
that her butt hurt stand oh my god
my grandma's favorite movie that I've
been in I would I would have to say
either oceans eight or crazyfish Asians
but I think oceans eight because she
keeps telling me she's like what's that
girl's name so funny
and I'm like Sarah Paulson and she's
like yeah I love her weeps every time
you have to start with somebody wait
what'd she do I turn it on Oh a least
favorite of my movies
probably the movie that I have a
masturbation scene in I don't know if
she enjoyed that all of them ah dude but
I I think that I actually think that my
grandma watched dude in which I had a
masturbation scene and she watched the
masturbation scene and didn't realize
what I was doing
so that's on me
[Music]
you